überhaupt nichts passiert absolut kein
problem
sagt franke
moment dann war ich mir kennen uns doch
bitte alle kings mini machen was auch
hallo hier kommt ja da kommt ihr
gekrochen bischoff wittrock das system
so jochen über ist das nimmer es tut mir
leid ich kann mich nicht erinnern wo
soll das gewesen sein hauptschule auf
der schanz vor die erste ecke guckt
unternehmen die haunschild erika die
versuche das ist erreichte zwar
mutig ab und wandert hat du hast das du
niedergerissen was das nimmer
was haben wir gesagt mensch klaus
jesse es tut mir leid ich heiße nicht
klaus in mein name ist jörg friedrich 1x
jörg friedrich klausi jörg friedrich mit
seinem miteinanders viertel aufgewachsen
ich komme aus heidelberg in der
brucknerstraße ich bin erst letztes jahr
hierher gezogen wir haben auch
miteinander fußball spielen viertel vor
nachher im tor ich hab noch nie fußball
gespielt ich fechte und nach dem spiel
haben wir heute die weit aufgerissen ich
bin schwul so lange schon immer dies ist
sehr lang ja gut dann kann uns
vielleicht doch mit nein dann haben wir
vielleicht doch getäuscht und die war
nur so sicher short klaus jörg friedrich
gut dann glaube ich verzögert die
holzwände belästigen haben sie nicht
einen tag nach gleichstand
servus hockey da ist der klausi du
glaubst es nicht wer mir gerade über den
weg laufe der wochen ist wieder in
ingolstadt und noch das gleiche
arschloch wie damals im piusviertel